[Music]
behind farm shed doors across australia
sits machinery worth hundreds of
thousands even millions of dollars
machinery purchases are big ticket items
for australian grain growers who are
often presented with differing opinions
around investment options
that's why grdc initiated a two-year
project to develop a comprehensive guide
for growers in australia's cropping
regions to support informed
decision-making around machinery
purchases farm machinery investment
questions are often labored over
and making sure that you've got
i guess
an investment that's adequate to do the
job
efficiently and effectively
is important first and foremost but also
making sure that you're not over
capitalised
the guide contains data relevant across
grdc's northern and southern cropping
regions
it features 30 case studies gleaned from
information provided by more than 450
growers including darren's andrew todd
who shared their machinery purchase and
ownership experiences compared to
industry averages for similar farm
operations
[Music]
andrew's machine investments are matched
to meet darren's low rainfall and sandy
soils constraints he says depreciation
which the guide examines is a big issue
in a market where new machinery values
are rising rapidly we picked this one up
second hand in february this year the
new ones
we priced up were
fairly ecsty and not available in time
for this year's program so pick this one
up used fair enough the guide's tools
include a new benchmarking formula for
growers to calculate their machinery
investment levels relative to their
overall farm profit
calculating the ratio against the
average is based on the value of a
growers farm plant adding labor costs
maintenance and contracting and then
pitching that against gross farm income
once they've done that that ratio of
those costs versus gross farm income
should be about 0.34 if you're on the
lower side of that you're more efficient
with your farm machinery investment than
perhaps other peers
if you're on the higher side you might
be a little bit over capitalised when it
comes to farm machinery the traditional
measure has been machinery investment
per
cropable hectare or perhaps per tonne of
grain produced where this guide or this
ratio if you like is
taking into consideration maintenance
labor and also the use of contracting
which is
very relevant and something that the
previous measures probably haven't taken
consideration of
the guide also encourages growers to
maintain an up-to-date machinery value
inventory especially with rising costs
and tighter access across machinery
supply
and the guide will be continually
updated to match changing industry
pressures
the ratio that has been developed there
will continue to evolve i think there
might be things that might get added to
that in time as farming businesses
change uh and of course you know we've
got challenges with uh
seasonal staff etc
and potentially you know the rise of
autonomy within a farm business might
see some of those numbers change a
little bit absolutely
[Music]